hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in st.
Augustine's on free choice of the will
we very understandably get quite a bit
of discussion of this Faculty of choice
that we call the will something that is
really at the core of our being in
Augustine's anthropology and this runs
throughout all of his work in fact the
the notion of the will as being
absolutely central in moral
decision-making and how we commit
ourselves in whether we position
ourselves rightly or wrongly in relation
to all the rest of the cosmos that's a
key theme that we see coming up over and
over and over again here one of the
central conceptions that we need to
think about is what is a good will and
one tempting way of understanding a good
will would be to say well you know
Augustine is a Christian so you know
whatever God says is good the will that
follows that is automatically a good
will and it's not quite so simple I mean
that will in fact be true and if we
understand what God is saying in terms
of the eternal law but that's not all
there is to the picture there's a much
richer
conception at work here of the will so
at one point in the discussion between
Augustine and his students in book 1 he
says that a good will is a will by which
we seek to live rightly and virtuously
in Latin recta monastic way
Viva reign and some people might quibble
and say oh it doesn't actually say
virtuously
but when we look at what it means to be
ho Ness day you know that's an adverb
how its living its living in accordance
with the four cardinal virtues so it's
pretty clear that that is an integral
part of it and that's not all that the
the goodwill does the goodwill also
wants to reach the heights of wisdom
that is in Latin odd Summum sap ENT
impaired van narrator to penetrate up to
the very heights or the very highest
points of wisdom so there's you could
say a kind of cognitive and conative
thing you know action-oriented and you
know there's also an affective side to
this as well
so there's there's a lot going on here a
good will is you could say kind of a
nexus within the human person of not
just doing the right thing choosing the
right thing but having the right motives
and valuing things properly so it's it's
quite complex what is this going to look
like in you know practical life well you
know we can get a bit of understanding
by looking at what he contrast this
against a will that is fundamentally
damaged screwed up getting things wrong
a little bit earlier in in the the work
he talks about how it's up to us it's up
to our will and our free choice of the
will whether or not we give into desire
or whether we you know choose something
else than than desiring temporal Goods
so he says there's a punishment if we
screw up what is the punishment it's not
going down to hell and getting poked
with you know pitchforks by demons and
flames or anything like that it's being
the screwed up thing that we are it's
having a damaged will that is unable to
really we'll what it ought to will so he
says the punishment is the mind being
ruled by passion being robbed of its
store of virtue being dragged to their
and their poor and needy now judging
false for true now defending now
attacking what before it approved and
then running off into false fresh
falsehood with holding its assent and
often frightened of clear reasoning
despairing of finding any truth at all
and clinging closely to the darkness of
its folly and then falling back to
exhaustion this is all sort of cognitive
stuff and then he says the passions rage
like tyrants throw into confusion the
whole soul in life of men who with
storms from every quarter fear on one
side desire on another on another
anxiety or false empty joy here pain for
the thing which was loved and lost
they are eagerness to win what is not
possessed their grief for an injury
received here burning desire to avenge
it and he goes on and on and on right
and he says that this is this is what
happens to a will that is not a good
will so what makes a will a good will if
we want to avoid that sort of internal
turmoil part of it is actually valuing
the goodwill
highly that is to the extent that it
should be valued and taking a great joy
in possessing it when we actually do
possess the virtues and a right way of
motivating ourselves when even when
we're just on the way moving away from
all of these vices and passions and
cognitive problems for going the right
way we can we might feel sad about you
know how screwed up we are but we can
feel good about the the what you know
measure of goodwill we do possess the
direction that we're going in we value
that more highly than anything else any
temporal thing and we
we take joy in it he says that is really
central to the the conception of the
goodwill this is what what he means by a
will by which we live to seek
righteously and virtuously and to reach
the height of wisdom he says I want you
to tell me how much you think is will is
worth do you think that riches or honors
or bodily pleasures or all of these
together bear any comparison with it and
the vodeo says no not at all very easy
for us though to think that well if I do
the wrong thing right now in order to
make a buck or in order to get some
pleasure I'll make up for it later you
know but we've already abandoned the
goodwill in doing that so he says do you
think that those who lack this joy
suffer a small loss and being deprived
of such a good and the vodiane says no
they suffer a great loss what's really
key to Augustine's way of looking at
things is that it is up to us whether or
not we have or keep the goodwill it's
it's our choice now you know very rarely
do we do we sort of lay it out for
ourselves and mental images and say aha
the goodwill or this pleasure right we
could do that if we were you know
thinking things through well but more
often we're like doing the right thing
exercising this virtue of prudence or
temperance or or justice and making a
couple extra bucks or getting an honor
or something like that you know which
usually involves doing something that we
know is too wrong like you know telling
a lie or maybe not even a complete lie
just puffing up our accomplishments or
letting a person believe something that
isn't strictly true we could go on and
on and on with examples right so it is
up to us he says he says it lies in the
power of our will whether we enjoy or
lack this great and true good why
what is so fully in the power of the
will as the we
itself it's up to the will whether or
not it's going to be a good will or a
bad will if it has a status of being a
goodwill it's up to us whether it keeps
being a goodwill and this does in fact
require the virtues and exercising those
virtues so it does require prudence
knowing what's you know good for us or
bad for us and putting that into
practice justice getting to everybody
what what they properly are owed you
know right order is part of that
temperance you know not giving in to to
all the desires and pleasures that we
might and then courage standing up
against fear and despising the some of
the things that we otherwise would be
very into so you know to go on we do in
fact as he says choose and keep the
goodwill but he goes a bit further to
have the goodwill strictly speaking
means to love the goodwill to feel a
kind of love towards oneself or that
part of oneself that not only does
choosing not only has this capacity to
like you know decide things and order
them and prioritize them but is properly
ordered so when we have this within
ourselves it's not like we should feel
you know proud in the bad sense but we
can look at and say wow that's really
something good it may not be perfect but
it is indeed something good that we
could take some some joy in so he says
this is what it means to have goodwill
there's a kind of reflexivity to it too
he says whether to love one's own
goodwill and value it as highly as we've
said is it self goodwill that's the
question and of odious says yes that is
indeed in when you have the goodwill
part of what it means to have the
goodwill is that that goodwill values
that goodwill in the right way and that
may be a little bit complex but it's
it's you know we can see a sort of
circularity
there or reflexivity as we said it is
also going to involve loving other thing
so among them it will involve loving the
eternal law and the eternal law is this
you know thing that Augustine thinks
provides moral norms for all other laws
it's the law coming from God it's also a
law that we're able to grasp by reason
it doesn't change from time to time and
place to place situation a situation it
remains right it remains the standard of
right and so having a good will means
loving the eternal law it also means
deserving happiness in accordance with
the eternal law as well and following
the eternal law because it is the
eternal law or put putting it another
way because it's right because it's
what's good for us so the eternal law
provides a set of standards that the
goodwill can use to structure itself to
guide itself and it even sort of
ratifies the fact that part of the
eternal law is if it doesn't do that
then it's gonna fall into misery
you know the eternal law dictates that
reward and Punishment happened through
happiness and misery and that the will
gets to decide between those so what is
this ultimately going to mean it's not
just about the eternal law it's not just
about looking within it'll also have to
do with how we arrange all of the other
goods in our life the temporal goods
which are in fact genuine goods pleasure
social status our relationships with
other people
well those are those sorts of things
what do we make of them if we have a
goodwill we make sure that the goodwill
always comes first and those things if
we have to choose between them and the
goodwill it comes second
but if we can enjoy them and use them
properly then that is actually the
goodwill and they can in fact according
to Augustine be used properly that is in
accordance with the eternal law so this
is a particularly robot
and reflexive conception of what it
means to possess a genuinely good will
as a human being as somebody who is
endowed with this faculty as part of our
very human nature and one thing I'll say
by way of closing this off is that in
other places Agustin talks about the
will itself as being a very great good
that we would not be as good as we are
even though we're very often quite bad
and screwed up if we lacked a free will
so this you know the right use of the
free will the good will is something
that's going to be of absolute
importance in Augustine's moral theory
you